he's my inside okay let me give you the
question an exponential equation because
I think you guys get Exponential's like
people understand them I basically
everyone understands infinity because
you know stuff that grows and the fat
but more there is of it the faster it
grows like say interest or depends what
part of the world let's say population
impacts okay or well it's free the
universe is not as obvious that it was
expanding anyway people used to think
that it would slow down because of
gravity honest nowadays spirituals okay
so if I gave you this equation I know we
usually have our equations in terms of
y's and x's but I'm doing really badly
avoiding that because it's very abstract
it's kinda like what's Y what's X the
point behind this that is it there could
be anything okay so here I'm giving you
these very specifically to refer to
things namely how much something grows
and how long it's been growing for okay
so here's my idea right exponential
equations are about how big something
has gotten if it's growing at a certain
rate for certain time okay
so this is you know your final amount
this is your rate and this is how long
this is your duration okay by the way
the reason why we're looking on e and we
use that so much when you match the
Exponential's is because it's the
pattern that everything follows if it's
growing continuously and things were
based on themselves okay so like a
population like bacteria okay the more
bacteria they are if you think about
this guy
this is compound interest right so as
this thing goes on and on and on and on
if we if we think about it like I saw
that every year and then every month and
then every week and then every day and
boil it down to like the smallest amount
of time that we can okay for instance if
we did it by day okay and you have like
an interest rate or some way that sorry
wrong way around that should be
okay so if you had any years this would
be 365 n will be how many days there are
right but you have to adjust the formula
yeah you've got to divide the rates by
however many time periods you've got
right now as these numbers here right
that 365 or however many of hours there
are okay as that increases as you take
as you take the limit okay all this
thing as is growing it approaches e
that's weird
hmm like that's where this number comes
from that's why it's random this is sort
of like just like pi comes from circles
e culture compound graph okay so that's
why now here's the important thing even
exponential equations are about how much
something has grown for incidence if you
got something and it's doubling okay
this is my growth rate okay and you let
it double for five periods of time what
that's telling you is by the end of your
final amount the actual amount it's
grown is there a third two times bigger
right if something doubles and you let
it do that five times now these are all
in index form so let's convert
everything into Log form and then we'll
see what this actually means okay how
would you rewrite this equation the top
one in what would the subject bear
the exponent becomes a subject okay and
then you get log so this would be base
the base of this becomes the base of
this okay so I better really log base E
I'm gonna write natural one okay and
then you're left with one more variable
right namely this okay so what have I
achieved by rewriting this okay this is
if you know how fast something is
growing and you know how long it goes
for you can know how big it will get in
there so this is the same question
rephrase in Reverse okay this is saying
if you know see there's that be hiding
there if you know the rate at which
something is growing and you know what
amount it will end up him right what's
your destination in terms of size okay
then you can also know how long it will
take
right okay yep okay so they say natural
log because when you're looking at log
base whatever or you know say this
growth rate right
the most common thing for us to ask you
know what's the rate okay the most
common number is this 2.718 number okay
it's sort of the the natural thing that
systems which grow like populations or
things which decay like radioactivity
they all tend towards this strange
mysterious number they're kind of not
entirely sure why just like why is the
ratio between a circles diameter and
it's sorry diameter and its
circumference why is it pi why is it
3.14 well it's just what it is in the
same way that's what should point seven
warnings okay okay so for that reason
that's why we use we use base E because
it's the most useful so these two things
same set of data right but they're
asking different questions
this one is what amount do I end up with
and this one is how long okay so this is
a growth question and this is a time
question so when I rewrite this okay I
would write this as log base to base
becomes the base rate of 32 I know the
rank and I know what I'm going to end up
in
so it's a question all and time so when
you see logs
you should think how long does something
take